[музика]
останні приготування напередодні 1
вересня ця школа в місті Буча хоче
забути жахіття окупації і знову
зустрічати дітей тут було розташовано
медикаменти під час окупації які тільки
можливо були тому що лікарня була вся
поранених і коли не вистачало поранених
з лікарні то ми їм тут облаштували
шпиталь протягом усього літа школи
ремонтували директорка показує розбиті
Двері які не встигли полагодити їх
виламали російські військові і все що
було в цьому кабінеті винесено навіть
елементарні особисті речі зрозуміла оце
не могли винести хто не винесли
у підвалі облаштували укриття це
обов'язково умова за якої можливе очне
навчання цій будівлі лише два роки
цокольний поверх просторий але з ним теж
довелося попрацювати за словами
директорки прибирали фарбували стіни і
розставляли меблі учителі разом з
батьками Це просто непридатне було
навіть щоб Там знаходились тут не було
повітря ми відновили вентиляцію ну як от
такого кольору було все
підлоги не було
нині Тут є три класні кімнати кінозал
тренажерна зала санвузли Лариса сторожек
розповідає Що сама перші кілька тижнів
від початку війни була в Бучі цей підвал
став прихистком для її родини і ще
чотирьох сотень людей потім з уже
окупованого міста жінка виїхала за
кордон повернулася щойно Бучу звільнили
від росіян і в мене було настільки
натхнення і радості від того що я тут
що ми зможемо
не пустити їх сюди знову А якщо буде
продовжуватися війна то діти будуть в
безпеці наразі всі 100% учнів 1 вересня
ідуть на заняття тільки різна форма одні
онлайн екстернат але всі учні які
навчалися до війни приступлять до занять
саме перейдуть в заклад дійсно менше
відсоток 60%, наприклад ті наприклад
онлайн хтось іще не доїхав з-за кордону
Ми чекаємо
після двох років карантину і півроку
війни 1 вересня на шкільному подвір’ї
знову гамірно Утім традиційної лінійки
немає кожна паралель класів збирається у
визначений час і рушає на перший урок
першокласниця євангеліна з нетерпінням
чекає коли познайомиться з новими
друзями сьогодні буде
хороший день батьки євангеліни вже
оглянули укриття в школі тому за свою
доньку спокійні були збори підготовчі
розповідали як буде йти в навчальний
процес ми готові до цього треба Життя
продовжується треба навчатися петиція на
сайті президента про заборону очного
навчання набрала 25 тисяч підписів серед
аргументів стурбованих батьків теж що
школи часто обстрілюють п'ята частина
шкіл дитсадків зруйновані мама
першокласника марка сподівається що в
Бучі такого більше не станеться Це
дійсно небезпека і Я кожного дня буду
розуміти що я віддаю дитину в школу і
можуть різні складки скласти обставини
але я надіюся Все буде добре не
лякається повітряних тривог із
шестикласник Владислав Він згадує як
поспіхом з батьками виїжджав з міста 24
лютого як бачив на відео ворожі
гелікоптери над своїм подвір'ям але
тепер каже готовий до всього і радий що
повернувся до школи
поки що не страшно страшно тоді коли ну
вони начинають стріляти або відправляти
ракети це тоді страшно або погати свої
ядерної бомбою це це страшно Олена
Андрієвич викладає у цій школі хімію і
біологію з цього року тут навчатимуться
і обидва її сини найбільше новому
навчальному року радіє молодший
шестикласник Максим ще робив вдома в
телефоні день на дивані А так хотів в
школу ходиш в друзі є ця родина вже
знайома з укриттям у школі підвал став
для них прихистком у перші два тижні
війни тепер вони кажуть що звикли до
нової реальності з повітряними тривогами
і постійною небезпекою до війни не можна
проникнути по страх війни того що ще
воно може сюди прийти Ну але так Ну все
добре Зараз підемо на навчання ну
хочеться відчувати що життя
налагоджується Життя іде далі діти
ростуть
здоров'я
мирне небо візьмемо у третьокласників
Перший урок це клас об'єднаний з двох
після побажань на новий навчальний рік
інструктаж що робити коли за виє сирена
далі діти діляться думками що для них
Україна говорять про війну українських
захисників і ворожих загарбників Але
який треба мати розум щоб такої біди нам
робити
у першої навчальний день у цій
бучанській школі про війну лише говорили
жодного разу дітям і вчителям не
довелося спускатися в укриття
[музика]